can start the panel
yes so
amit wanted to say a quick word
so yes you can say
sure no i just wanted to um just just to
very quickly
uh thank the uh simon's institute
on behalf of uh jls on behalf of rachel
and ayush
uh and me just uh that the uh the last
last semester program which was sadly
interrupted by the pandemic
was actually where some of the ideas
behind our work
were sort of initially pondered
thank you for that thanks amit
yes and and we are going to have
a official panelist i would not mind
that all if people
uh make this again like like the talks
that can be interactive people cannot
mute themselves they
ask questions and as i mentioned before
if you're an attendee and you cannot and
you want to be able to unmute yourself
and ask questions
just raise your zoom hands and we want
you to
listen then
so again i guess i'm not
as usual i'm not going to do
introductions
maybe this is the only one that hasn't
spoken before so we're very happy to
have our lattice expert chris
mr and bernie as the official panelists
but again
other people would weigh in as well and
i think this is an area that is worth
talking about in crypto this is
the computational assumptions maybe the
one
the one part where
we are really different than other
fields of
computer science theoretical computer
science and mathematics
maybe the more subjective
objective part of our
and i don't think we have
no one has exactly rules what is a
what is a standard assumption what is a
non-standard assumption what is a valid
assumption what is a heuristic what is
it
and i hope you can talk about it but let
me start with this question that
i made asked in the break and that
sounds to me like a good question to ask
our
panelists so
suppose you had to bet your life or i
don't know bet something very
important to you uh on the security
on and of course we do use sometimes
compositional assumptions to protect
very sensitive things so it's not
completely hypothetical
but suppose you you had to uh very
bet your um you know bet something very
important to you
on the security or
so which of the assumptions you would be
most shocked
if they were false say of the four
assumptions used in jls so you can also
talk about some
those cousins of them if you like and
maybe you can start with chris because
he hasn't talked
yet sure so
i guess there's two questions uh that we
could consider
you know emits version was gun to your
head which
uh of these assumptions do you bet your
life on
and uh i think i can give an answer to
that i mean i think my answer is
probably the same as benny's and yours
met which is
you know the prg and nc0 but um
we could flip it around and say
something uh
what's that what is that based on it
so i think it's i don't think i have
very anything you know that
that's particularly original to say
about this and benny
probably would say it better but it
seems like you know the least structured
of all of these
uh a purely combinatorial kind of uh
statement um of course we don't really
know that
it's implied by any of the others uh or
implies any of the others so
we can't formally compare any of these
things but
um just just the combinatorial aspects
to it
no geometry no uh no nothing really
um so yeah it also has the five-year-old
it passes the five-year-old test right
that a five-year-old
could construct a prg in nc zero that
would be hard for the real most
brilliant mathematician to break
yeah and it's interesting to me that
because the christian bet your academic
life on
lwe you took my you took my question
away so
so you said we want to make this
slightly more uh slightly less morbid
uh you know you ask what are you going
to bet your career on the answer is
clear
but the third version of this question
is gun to your head a gunman knows which
of these state
which of these assumptions are false
okay so one of these four is false
gun to your head what is it right now
this is a trickier question i think than
the the first one
um you know there's a gun to my head so
i have to say something
but i might be saying sxdh
even though it's relatively older than
all of the rest of them
um that's what i would be and and let's
like slightly less morbid if we're going
to attack something and
try to say like i don't believe the
implications of these four assumptions
one of them must be false
then which one should i you know try to
chip away at
maybe sxdh is the one to to focus
one's effort on um and you know we could
say more about it i'm sure
everyone else has thoughts about that
too um but how much can we say
that it actually has been investigated
by uh
by cryptanalysts let's say it's been
around a long time for sure
um from my opinion any problem that i
haven't
uh actually studied is actually easy and
just people haven't figured out how to
break it
like i thought lattices were easy and
then i started looking at them and
that's like
how i got into it so uh you know i don't
have anything intelligent to say about
sxdh other than
oh of course it's you know breakable
just people haven't thought hard enough
about it
but uh yeah i would be interested in
other people's opinions on uh
on this third question as well you
should try to find clicks
yeah and alex points out right it's
already broken with quantum computers
so how much farther
we really need to go to break it also in
some sense f6h is the most structured
right this is like elliptic curve the
electric curves are laden with structure
and so that's another reason to be but
on the end it has been the one that is
i think by far the most script analyzed
of all of all the assumptions
of all four because that's xdh because
it's used in practice so widely
um or these bilinear maps are used in
practice or you know
well i think they've just been an
incredible amount of mathematical
cryptanalysis
the two questions of the two questions
of
uh of chris or maybe three but let's say
two
which assumptions we don't have to
involve
guns but uh perception are you the the
ones that you are most certain that is
secure and which assumptions you're
the most suspicious of yeah so for me
i see your point with less structure
means probably more security i
understand the sentiment but for me i
think a big part is how much
uh um wiggle room does the assumption
give me for example
uh if you ask me if goldar's one-way
function
is secure is not the same of asking is
there
a prg in nc 0 or even asking
essex dh are you asking me is dh secure
in group i don't know 2
whatever the numbers are or does there
exist a bilinear
group for which sxh is secure is a
different type of assumption
so i i'm kind of a little more
comfortable
uh with the wiggle room that i feel like
okay maybe you know
this is false but i can try to move to a
different assumption
so um in that sense i feel i agree
that i feel also if i had to choose one
assumption to rely on i would
choose prg because you know if god has
broken i'll find something else there's
a lot of options out there
uh with regard to sxth
i'm not sure i share uh the sentiment
that it's the easy
that that would be my choice for the
easiest because i feel like
exactly like i said no groups there
doesn't exist
any group for which i know we don't have
that many candidates but
you know who knows maybe you know five
years from now we'll have an amazing
multilingual map candidates
so i mean mathematics is an evolving
field and
so yeah so i'm not sure i think the
specific assumptions
you know these worry me a little bit
more uh
because why because you know i mean i
trust that we're all very smart here but
come on you know we're all muggles and
a you know it's uh
but however going back you know the fact
that things are broken with quantum
computers is a bit is uh a big uh
a down you know um
a downer so i'm kind of contradicting
myself so maybe i'm not happy with sxdh
i'm not happy with the fact that it's
broken with quantum computers i am happy
with the wiggle room
so but i would choose definitely prg as
my
go-to interestingly i think uh
shows algorithm maybe even if you forget
about the
very real things that people are
building quantum computers shows
algorithm
also showed maybe that these things
don't have as much wiggle room as
you think because it broke all of them
in one shot so it's
so at least presumably it's possible
that the classical algorithm will just
break all of them
in manchester that's a very good point i
i yes
benny
yeah i also agree with everything that
was said
let me at one point i think that um
let me try to you know to give an
external answer right i mean i'm not
regardless of my own private
point of view given an assumption x i
think that it's more
it's more reliable if people who
understand this domain of x
really try to break it because there's
no chance that i will be able to break
you know by linear groups because i
don't know enough about the mathematical
structure of the of very narrow maps
and i'm not sure like i look before this
talk i try to
i plan to prepare a few slides about
this sxdh
and i couldn't find i found many people
who used it of course
but they couldn't find a lot of crypto
analysis and i wonder like
maybe this is a question i'm not making
a statement because i
because of my ignorance right but i
wonder how many
mathematicians like real mathematicians
look at
this problem and on the other hand
if you go to gold i for example i think
that
this kind of question about csp is
basically this is
we we are the kind as a community right
we are the kind of people who are
supposed to to solve it
right if it's solvable and indeed you
know with this the whole thing with the
degree to
a over there over the wheels right the
whole thing it was broken right i mean
when
you guys found the attacks because you
work on these kind of things and this is
the right community to study this
problem
so my confidence here is is mainly based
on the fact that
when we talk not about not personally
myself but as a community when we talk
about the
local plgs in a sense we
specifically understand them better than
we understand the
other things i mean that actually
reminds me i think maybe shafi remembers
is that money who said something like
that factoring is a better assumption
than aes
because uh if factoring will be broken
it will be broken by someone we know
like copper smith or something like that
and if a yes will be broken it will be
broken by
who knows why someone we don't know
it'll be broken by google deep mind or
something like that right i mean it'll
be uh
the attack will be uh completely opaque
to us maybe even
in the sense that we won't know that
they attacked it or that they we
don't understand the attack we won't
understand even what the attack does i
mean this is a
to me an entirely plausible possibility
i don't know i'm not saying it'll happen
but
uh right i mean it solved go this this
game that was completely inaccessible to
computers and and it's beating uh you
know the best
human uh with you know a couple days of
training on what the rules of go are and
then all of a sudden it's
defeating world champions forever like
we should set
deep mind against aes and see what
happens
let it first solve lpm without noise
sure seriously
just one really quick thing about sxth
just so that we
are all on the same page
ah sorry my connection uh maybe maybe
i'm not going to be the best moderator
because my connection is not super great
but uh maybe if i have a little bit of
internet i'll try to use it to ask the
next
question so i wanted to say something
about s60
i'd love to hear it yes just just we
were actually talking earlier rachel
and and some of us that in fact um
it's not like we really need sxgh
specifically
so um if you're worried about that um
we can also use for example something
called bilateral kalin
and they're they're like a whole family
of bilinear assumptions so
all the crypto nouns that you were that
you did see on bilinear maps like
most of those kinds of uh things are
relevant and we can we can
play with which assumptions specifically
where we're um
we're working with there so we it just
just that's all i want to say
so so maybe um next question
is the following i i kind of remember um
a panel in in the celebration for shafi
and silvio i think there was also
discussion of computational assumptions
and i am trying to remember exactly the
sentiment but i remember
there was some people that are kind of
concerned about
the how how many assumptions are
how the field has changed from the days
where you have to apologize for ddh
to er the days that every
every paper introduces at least one new
assumption and
preferably with five different heuristic
on top of it and
and some people thought even maybe we
should have like some kind of a
moratorium on
introducing assumptions or things like
that
so i wonder what what do people think
about it is
should we have some discipline should we
are there any rules
how do we evaluate how do we explain
when we sit on probably
on program committees how do we explain
to non-cryptographers uh what is kosher
and what is not
and i don't know maybe this time we do
the inverse order benny yeah and then
chris
um i i can say two things so first of
all i
kind of personally i changed my mind
about this this subject like
i think that i was very conservative in
the past and now i think that
we have i think that we should balance
between these two things like a
avi gave a talk in tcc last week two
weeks ago i don't remember exactly
and he said i don't remember the exact
uh
citation but he said that we show and
then someone
told us this is impossible let's do it
that was the spirit in the early days of
crypto
and i think that this spirit is super
important and part of this
spirit is you know to have the um they
have the guts to make assumptions
right and sometimes to make
sub-exponential assumptions and they say
you know super polynomial things that
seems like a
maybe sins but they really advance us
on the other hand i think that we should
be skepticism we should try to
understand the assumptions and in this
aspect
i wouldn't limit the number of
assumptions but i would be happy to see
more papers not about applications i
mean
applications are great but also about
like basic assumptions like a
try to relate a to b or i don't know try
to understand it what are the known
heuristics what are the known attacks
what are the bottlenecks and i think
that we need more of these kind of
things
just to compare you know in in
complexity right i mean
basing uh uh doing the randomization
based on search assumptions right i mean
this is kind of a huge amount of effort
you don't just assume a prg right and
and also in crypto right i mean we
wouldn't have like hail or extractors if
people would say okay
pseudo-randomness is there and that's it
anyway we don't want to base it on
one-way functions
so i think that also from this effort of
reducing to simpler assumptions we also
gain a lot of insights and a lot of
tools so
so we should basically push these two to
two extremes they
understanding the assumptions and
generating new ones i think that both
are crucial
hey me i i i completely agree with you
benny
100 uh i want to also say one thing
which
amit talked about which is uh you know
is about reductions
it's about an algorithm that reduces one
problem to another
and if the reduction is interesting and
there's good ideas there then it's
meaningful
uh so and that's i think how how the
field moves
and i think um i agree with with
benny that me i think also in the past
there was like
there was a point of time where just
every paper had a new
assumption and i think we were all kind
of oh my
you know stop this this is crazy but
actually looking
five years kind of ahead it was pretty
good look where we are now you know and
it's because we dared
so i think the point is we should
understand that sometimes
the way we move is by generating a mess
and cleaning it up
and if we're worried about generating
the mess
maybe we won't move forward so i think
that
and we learned that even you know i'm
just looking back even let me
give another example which is very
different and not messy you know
we change mod like even looking back you
know going back to the example of zero
knowledge proofs you know they want zero
knowledge proof they completely changed
the model tons of interaction
now we're back and we're you know going
back to the original no interaction crs
but
it you know we need to dare to change
to assume to change and then
slowly we'll get back to where kind of
we are intended to originally
so we need to be careful being too
conservative but
one but the other hand i agree generally
too much rest can be you know
problematic so it's a a you need a good
path kind of
yeah you the two of uh benny and yael
took everything i wanted to say
maybe a surprise i don't know uh you
know i i don't find
myself very daring in terms of uh
assumptions that i make but
i i do want to echo uh what benny said
about and and also yael said
about uh and lament a little bit that
um when we do have new assumptions we
don't as often
have relations between them as much as
we would
we really ought to and uh i feel like
there's a kind of a publishing problem
which is that if people work
on attacking an assumption for a while
and don't get anywhere this kind of work
apparently seems to get kind of lost
right and may never ever get
see the light of day and people may
never know that may never know and they
may have been
you know the work that was put in may
have been just you know one step away
from yielding something
really interesting either constructive
or destructive
um i don't know what the solution is to
that right when people do
good crypt analytical work of course it
gets published because it actually is
something to show for it
um and when people do attempt
constructive work also
they and it doesn't work out for
whatever reason often there's
there's no publication coming out of it
um i i
i probably a hypocrite on this myself
right every time i
i've tried dozens of things and and they
don't work out and
who has time to write it up who has time
to uh to talk about it and
and make it formal you know we have
informal networks and things like that
where we tell people oh i tried this i
tried that
but um you know in terms of
efforts that don't uh pan out
um i really wish we had a better way of
broadening the uh the the
distribution of that um
and then i just wanted to add one more
thought about making
you know bold assumptions and things
like that actually when you know when we
say lwe
that's a very overloaded term and i
think that we are making
a pretty bold assumptions about lwe with
great
benefits uh a lot of the time so when
when we say lwe with
you know modulus to noise ratio it's
actually a pretty
bold assumption uh many of the
reductions like search to decision they
kind of
they break down unless you're willing to
pay the the sub-exponential time
uh you know as benny mentioned in his
talk um
i i don't know that we're all that super
confident that
uh let's say two to the root n
approximation for shortest vector is
is all that hard i mean we know we can
do it in two to the root end time
um you know there could be a part of the
spectrum here that
that's that we don't really understand
all that well and
um you know people have certainly looked
at it ll was content with
exponential factor approximations but
i think that in that huge spectrum uh
we're being pretty bold and we've we've
done well
uh with it but i'd like
people to think more about uh the whole
the whole spectrum of of from the actual
assumption we're making to
the the problems that it's related to
and where the gaps are there that would
be nice to see more of
maybe to your point of um of of
publishing a work that tries to
talk about failed approaches uh i think
maybe there's two communities
that we can learn from to some extent
one is
a crypto analytic community they
actually often
you know if they cannot break a block
cipher they look at a reduced version of
it and and that's very
uh that's very agreed etcetera so they
modify the assumption and they break the
modified assumption and that's
another thing is that sometimes have
like very weak attacks but they show
something
i remember i think i saw a talk once by
adi shamir
where he showed you could break aes with
a 256
block length in uh two to the power i
don't know two to the 40 or something
like that it was
like you know you know very you you
instead of two to the power two with 256
you do it two to the two
to the power 240 but it's still
interesting because you show that you
shape something and
in the other communities of course a
complexity where you know if you cannot
break something you try to
prove barrier results that these
techniques will not do it and it's not
that we don't do that
in in cryptography but maybe we should
do more in the sense that
if you try something and fail try to
abstract what what is this that you
tried and publish that
yeah that's a great point and also i
think we probably don't have enough
papers of the form you know algorithm
from class
x is you know provably not able to
defeat this
maybe it's much harder to do in our in
our field or maybe it's just not
traditionally
done i don't know what do other people
think about that
so i have one thought about this which
is you know we make up all our
assumptions
you know and but who tries to to really
crypt analyze these assumptions that we
make it's not us
very few of us chris maybe you but most
of us
or yeah but like most of us 90 percent
of the time
not more we just wanna construct this
construct that a better this a better
that
and new primitives and it's very
exciting whereas taking someone's
assumption and trying to break it
it's it's a little less exciting if it's
your own you definitely don't want to
break it and if it's someone else okay
so you work so hard and
it somehow i feel like it we don't get
it doesn't get the
splash that kind of or the joy but it's
this may be my only personal
uh you know for me that's how i feel uh
i know we're different and some people
may completely feel the opposite
but i think that's a problem because
it's so much for me it's so much more
fun to make assumption than build
as opposed to be a downer but maybe it's
a personality i'm optimistic kind of by
nature
i want to add some something here which
is i think we should all remember
that like we're not this is not a glory
driven field we are
when we make assumptions when you do
something cool with an assumption
we're painting a big target right on
something and that's the way we should
always approach
all the constructive aspects of our
field that we are painting bigger and
bigger targets on certain problems
and i hope that now there are four very
big driving they're already big targets
or
elderly and think of it and now they're
like very big targets on the other
things and
that's how we should look at it right
that we and by the way i highly
recommend breaking your own assumptions
like we've done at the ayush's you know
these are these are targets for us to
attack we shouldn't think about it in
terms of this is my assumption i don't
want it to get broken no
no we should make it ourselves but even
standalone there are pretty interesting
questions like just like
mathematical it's like a simple
polynomial
can you find roots like it's just that
curiosity is enough
just to relate to the points it will
mention that i think that
as a first step like i totally agree and
i think that as a community we should
encourage this kind of research
as i said before but as a first step we
should try
harder to make the assumptions more
precise
and i think that um chris
may correct me but but in many lwe
papers that you read
i think people don't even bother to
state what is exactly
the exact variant of lwe which is being
used i'm not talking about the
the abstract right i would expect to see
it in the absolute but even in the
introduction or even in the
during the the paper and this is kind of
i think that
it's okay that you don't want to i don't
know to like it's okay that some of us
will
work on breaking assumptions and others
will work on generating new schemes
that's perfectly fine but i think that
we should all try to be
very precise in this kind of things and
and by the way this is what allows
someone like addie chanel to state
that he can shave something because the
assumption the original assumption
was very very accurate or at least it
was understood as a very accurate
statement
if you don't have accurate statement you
cannot even show like a partial progress
because there is nothing to relate to
so i think that this is something that
as a community we should learn
both from complexity theories and from
crypto analysis
a good question let me maybe i'll ask it
and then maybe i
can continue i'm wondering if you state
a new assumption
i guess there are two kind of schools of
thought one would be
try to state the minimal assumption that
uh
implies uh the particular primitive so
be conservative try to state the minimal
assumption that implies the primitive
that you are trying
to deduce the other is paint an even
bigger target and be in
and be as bold as possible and try to
spend the cleanest
strongest assumption that you don't know
that it's false and
what do you think is better
you should do both i think you should
say exactly what you know and what you
don't know and
you know it suffices to assume this but
as far as we know maybe even
this is how to break right and that's
that's what you should do
well we don't even know how to break
this valiant thing
can you switch the subject for a second
from the assumptions or is the point of
topic assumptions
we we can uh we we can
be flexible i'll be happy to hear it i i
i'll be happy for you
okay so here there's a construction now
there's several constructions
uh and it's sort of early
yeah in the sense that just like fhe
original paper
of of gentry seemed to
generate a lot of a lot of research but
to begin with people didn't think that
this could become a real
system but it is real system and these
days actually you can
utilize fhe for real applications even
at scale
so i know that right now we just
finally some construction where people
are starting to believe that this can be
concretized what are the projection in
your opinion
it's obviously not going to be this
construction but that this could
actually be useful
uh in the sense that somebody would
actually implement it and again i i
um some of you were in the darpa program
uh when fhe was and
it was clear that that's kind of the
wrong question to ask and want to do a
lot of research
yes the fact that there was this darpa
program and the fact that a lot of money
was put in
in order to make it efficient and to
make the assumptions sort of more
you know uh i think it gave it a huge
boost
to to get where we are today so so that
me as a theoretician who's now an age
where
in hebrew would say heaven i am
actually asking you a little bit of a
concrete question what would
be your projections
i think for functional encryption a
reasonable goal is to get it as
efficient
as fhe that might take
i don't know five years uh
optimistically if it can be done but i i
don't see that why that cannot be done
from functional encryption to io because
of this
exponential tree business i don't have a
good
understanding of what's so complex there
but i think getting functional
encryption as efficient as
state-of-the-art
fhe is a
ambitious but plausible median term goal
for the community i agree with rachel on
this
on on that but i think also for io
for or off the station in general you'll
have to find
other recipes that are much more
efficient before they can
example and there are there is line of
work that's um that's going on that
road right so with ayush and um
several other authors of duvall and marx
andre and others
for example we recently looked at some
coding based constructions
for io that are much more heuristic of
course in terms of
security but you know large factors more
efficient
um than right now it's still not
that efficient but it's significantly
more efficient so i think that
probably very different um recipes
will come up but as we understand better
it'll that'll happen i think that
the near-term next step is the same as
with fhe
streamlining right i think but now we
first have we finally have
a construction based on something
and we just tried to get it based on
everything we have
streamline it understand it and then
start to tear away the different
parts this five-year
um yes is an interesting one
uh so for example if i wanted to just
use it for public encryption
you know to transform secret key systems
out there
to public key systems uh that's another
thing that's short of
general construction right and that you
would like you might be interested in
doing that efficiently
you know for quantum based schemes or
something like that
right hey
i want i want to say that uh you know
i'm actually very optimistic i know it's
my nature but i am because
we see the history you know it's not the
fhe is not the first look at pcps
i remember when i was a student at mit
and
ellie bensasson was there and a bunch of
others and i remember who thought
it's never going to be used ever ever
and it was everybody agreed it was like
a consensus of course never
now you know they're used you know
there's companies that make money
it's used by millions of people i don't
know if they make it they don't make
money maybe they don't make money but
it's used
they make money maybe the investors are
not making money but they are making
money
they get investors and turn over their
money
[Laughter]
so you know so so why not here you know
we just started it's like a
uh we're in diapers so i i it's hard for
me to put numbers in terms of how many
years
but uh why not if we work hard then yes
yeah i i don't know if pcps make money i
think that some of them may
make a little bit of money but
definitely they have improved by
something like
i i forgot i saw a talk once say 30
orders of magnitude
so the way they do make
money
they literally literally make money they
they mine money
in ten years maybe that would be the
only form of money
so you think this is an approach then
that if you're because i i've seen an
interesting uh trajectory which uh
30 years ago systems people were not
interested at all in what the artisans
do
today it's very very different so
they're building uh systems based on
ideas from theory
sometimes even claiming proofs you know
using sort of general proof techniques
so would you say that someone with an
eye or five years ahead or four years
hair from systems
should try to understand in general
strokes what's going on in the
obfuscation world because
it will give them some insight on you
know where to set their targets i mean
possibly the answer would be
wait for two years you know i think wait
for a
few years at least but i'm also
i'm also very optimistic like yeah
definitely
functional encryption is so well
motivated in potentially in practice
that
that could be actually it may well be
a good idea in terms of for someone's in
systems to
try to imagine if they had a magical
functional encryption what would they do
with it and then
uh go and talk to people like uh rachel
and amit and
and and daniel and zika and everyone
here on the
everyone here and see how
maybe it variant maybe
it can happen we i think we should
remember too that
just like with fhe you know functional
encryption
for you know very specific highly
tailored
kinds of functions it's entirely
plausible that within five
or seven i don't know some some small
number of years
that that that will be you know a piece
of cake
uh we'll have we'll have new recipes
with new paradigms
new constructions and then people will
set on optimizing the hell out of it
for the specific application that
they're working on
and they'll be doing amazing things that
you know even
even accounting for this prediction will
still be amazing right in in five or
seven years
uh so yeah i i i feel no
qualms at all about the optimism that
everybody's
expecting uh despite feeling like i
should be a devil's advocate or
something
it seems like it seems like a very easy
bet uh
from from my perspective historically
wait wait
where's vika speak are you online well i
guess it's too late
it's supposed to be
so one other question so uh quantum
right so there's one i've asked people
have asked questions about quantum pcp
quantum fhe
these things keep to be start you know
what they keep happening
what about quantum obfuscation and that
is obfuscation with respect to
one quantum matrices or you know
fiscation for quantum computations
uh i did i had some thoughts about this
pre-prepared so can i jump in on this um
so one thing that's that's really
interesting looking
at uh like the the jls work versus the
works that have that that have built uh
uh
kind of on the ideas and principles but
then are
you know plausibly post-quantumly secure
um one big distinction that has become
even more clear
in my mind after watching all the talks
uh
the the great talks made this very clear
to me which is that you know the
the sxdh and bilinear maps are really
offering this degree to
functional encryption from which
everything can kind of be
be built upon that to get to get higher
degree
and uh that's not the case if you limit
yourself to the lattice and
and combinatorial uh assumptions that
are you know
plausibly post quantum um which to me
seems like a really interesting
qualitative uh distinction
um and that was one reason why you know
when when the gun was to my head
40 minutes ago that i thought that you
know maybe sxdh is the is where to chip
away because somehow
the constructions um
that are involving it are really getting
a lot of
juice from from the ssd sxdh and
bilinear
pairings versus uh what the more recent
constructions are doing
um one point i wanted to to bring up
there's this
really interesting paper with several
interesting papers now
uh with plausibly post quantum uh
constructions and uh one of them is by
daniel wicks and and hotek we which
has this interesting tool uh
called like oblivious lwe sampling and
i'm i'm going to oversimplify it in what
i'm about to say
but basically it's this assumption that
you have a public algorithm
that can sample uh the the b part the
right-hand side of a
of an lwe sample obliviously kind of
without knowing
the the secret and the error behind it
and um
i i'm not claiming that this is suspect
in any way but one thing i would
want people to to take a look at on that
is
like the question of oblivious lwe
sampling actually comes up
uh in regards original work on lwe and
he kind of says like if we had a way to
do oblivious uh
lwe sampling in other language that we
could actually solve
quantumly we could solve lattice
problems and so
to me this raises a really interesting
question of
does an oblivious lwe solver a sampler
excuse me does an oblivious lwe sampler
um
you know in some sense perhaps related
to what what daniel and hoteck
uh looked at not exactly but does that
imply a quantum algorithm for
for lattice problems and uh if so then
that would sort of
almost negate the conjectured quantum
security of that construction
i want to just mention that actually
this oblivious lw sampler is implied by
i o
so if uh if oblivious lw sampling is
suspected as a notion not just our
construction
then uh you know all the other works i
guess are also suspect
any any construction value will be
suspect yeah so that's very interesting
yeah so that's very interesting the the
formula the exact formalization of of
the
of the oblivious lw symbol is extremely
important here
um and so you know the details matter a
lot
but um it's something that i think is
really interesting to look into because
it could imply some kind of
you know really interesting quantum uh
implications
uh or or not but you know certainly
worth a close look
so if you could just and again on one
hand you're saying
that uh for the right definition of
oblivious library sampler
uh if it exists then you could quantumly
break
lwe yes yes so what does that mean then
um but again as as daniel pointed out we
given io we actually do have oblivious
samplers according to really strong
definitions of bluetooth sampling
so um yeah so the question would be
something like
does io uh imply
you know the quantum easiness of of
lattice problems or something of this
nature
right that that would be
an amazing kind of result i don't think
it's going to be that clean and simple
of a statement
in the end if anything holds but you
know something of that nature
seems really interesting to investigate
you're the perfect person to investigate
it too i mean
send me an email if you have ideas or
want to think about it further
boys just wrote a question and he says
in regex sampler i think it's important
you are able to forget
the coins you use no right yeah so
this gets to the details which i i don't
feel qualified to like
pontificate on you know in in uh in in
this
this venue but um the point of reggie's
uh what
in regards reduction he he
non-obliviously
samples what is essentially an lwe
instance and then uses quantum to forget
uh the coins right and then
once if you can do that then you can
actually use
the resulting quantum state to uh solve
lattice problems in a
with a much more machinery uh so
the question is whether uh an oblivious
lwe sampler can sufficiently play the
role
of uh something that creates uh
without you know knowing the coins or
having forgotten the coins
so chris is this is this in the original
regular paper i'll be uh yeah be very
curious to take a look
there might be very important
differences i think maybe one thing that
i couldn't easily imagine being a big
distinction is in our case the oblivious
lw sampler is that
you're given the public matrix a and
you're generating lw samples with new
secrets s
and i think in um in the the
regif case i would imagine it's the
opposite that uh
you're you're generating fresh samples
with the same secret as right
uh no no not so much so you you the a
roughly corresponds to the lattice and
you want to generate a point that's
close to the lattice without actually
knowing the
solution to it so it's
you know i'm not saying there's any
results here uh that's easy but uh it
seems
analogous maybe you can get a loose news
right maybe yeah
but i think shafi had a shafia the
question
no no i i i asked i um
i just wanted to clarify a that i
understood what chris was saying
so part of what you're saying is that if
there's quantum possibly
a io implies the quantum easiness of lwe
uh now what about the second part
obfuscation for quantum computation
i'll uh i'll i'll let someone else talk
about that i think
so wait i see it's vika asked a question
it's vika are you here
since you asked a question i think you
made a comment that uh basically i was
saying that
this is a reduction it's not an
algorithm and the reduction uses a black
box the
bound and decoding solver and chris
was wondering whether io
would be able to replace it and there is
also a good question uh
whether this oblivious is statistically
oblivious or competitively oblivious but
maybe this is not to go into
no but but it's vika since your face was
here can you put it back
maybe he's in pajamas well okay so but
can you hear us without a face
no pajama and no nothing listen what do
you think about
a uh that aya will be what do you think
about the question whether i o will be
a efficient enough for use
at some point in the near future
to see where i think we're going uh we
can wait until tomorrow
um i think i don't know um
it seems like it's going in maybe it's
going a direction where you could
consider
implementing but it's still there's so
many
it seems so indirect right you need to
go through so many transformations in
order
in order to make it work uh and i'm sure
somewhere somebody
is working on on sort of uh stripping it
and making it more uh
uh sort of direct construction um
so we'll see i mean i don't know people
still implement obfuscation right so
maybe
now people try to implement these new
things and maybe we'll
we'll see some uh some good things from
that okay so that's it
i was saying if sneaker the pessimist is
optimistic here
we're done you know so that's it i feel
like we are in a very very optimistic
place right now it's three o'clock too
so i think we really are done
it's one am here so you know one a.m yes
i feel like i'm not actually committed
to anything that i've said
so i have a question this is about like
quantum computers in general
uh do you think that i mean in order to
break these assumptions sxth and
everything
you probably need fully scalable quantum
computers right like lots of
bits the like is there any
hope that will have something in 10
years
um well the people means no the people
who build them say
if you give me a billion dollars i'll
get you one in 15 years
now maybe they're just trying to get a
billion dollars but uh
but uh you know that that's that's
roughly how they're budgeting
uh budgeting it as far as i understand
so um you know i
15 15 years with uh you know a one
percent
probability that seems pretty
significant to me
so we'll both quantum save io for half
as much
yeah yeah exactly
let me thank everyone so i can release
the people at 1am and at
3pm maybe an open problem for people to
think about
is how can we buy or more expensive so
we can
also come up with a billion dollar
budget
you can always run it fully
homomorphically there we go
all right thanks guys thank you so much
yes that's the next fhe under
over still tomorrow till tomorrow
tomorrow
for the people worried about quantum the
the
quantum future is tomorrow so uh so see
you all tomorrow
bye everyone thanks to all the speakers
thank you
thanks everybody thank you thank you
everybody for really interesting day